[MUSIC PLAYING]
RETO MEIER: I'm Reto Meier.
STEPHANIE WONG: And
I'm Stephanie Wong
here with Amit Zavery, VP of
Engineering, to dive into APIs.
Welcome and thanks
for joining us here.
AMIT ZAVERY: Sure.
Thanks for having me.
STEPHANIE WONG:
So I want to talk
about APIs, which
have come a long way
from the software interfaces
popularized by Win32 APIs.
Tell us where they are today
and your predictions for API
in 2019 and where AP
Apigee lies in this space?
AMIT ZAVERY: Sure.
Sure.
I think they look at what's
going on in the industry today.
There are many things
which are driving
the modernization of a lot of
existing applications, right.
So APIs are becoming the front
end to a lot of the assets
companies have already
in their portfolio.
And they unlock a lot of those
content for different kind
of users, be it end users, be it
partners, as well as employees.
So I think if you look
at going forward in 2019,
you'll start seeing a lot of
different ways of exposing
those APIs.
One, a lot of
companies are using,
trying to monetize on them,
to be able to kind of use that
to create a lot of new content,
as well as partnerships.
So we have a lot of good
examples of customers,
like say Magazine
Luiza in Brazil,
who is trying to create a lot
of e-commerce kind of content
and be able to expose a lot of
data to the end user to buy it.
Same thing with
AccuWeather, where
they want to be able to now
take a lot of the weather data
and share it and make it
available to a lot of other end
users as well.
So that's one kind
of driving factor.
Second thing is popularization
of a lot of ways of interfacing
through voice and text.
[INAUDIBLE],, UC, of
course, a different kind
of consumer devices.
And that requires
a lot of interfaces
into the back end
systems, and be
able to expose it
through voice and text.
So that's also driving
a lot of interest
from companies to be able to
use API management for that.
And third area we've seen
a lot of driving factor,
and you'll see a lot of
it as we move forward,
is a lot of industry
requirements.
So there's a lot of open
standards coming out, a lot
of regulations coming out.
And APIs is the one
way to log the content
and make sure they're
secured and they are
available to the right people.
So that's another
complete new requirement
we're seeing, and becoming very
popular as we move forward.
RETO MEIER: That's exciting.
Now, obviously, a lot of
APIs that drive ecosystems
are publicly visible.
But many of the APIs
at any given company
are only used internally.
How does Apigee support
both of those use cases?
AMIT ZAVERY: Sure.
So I think the way we have built
our platform at the Apigee area
was to really make
sure that anybody who
wants to expose
API, we provide them
ways to manage
the whole process,
be it internal or
external users.
And so the platform is really
kind of agnostic of that fact.
But we, of course, provide
a lot of safeguarding
when it's externally exposed.
A lot of the right
kind of regulations,
the right kind of permissions,
security elements are built in.
Similarly inside when
you're trying to expose it
inside the enterprise.
And we do use it between
different employees
for different
application development.
Again, we provide the whole
lifecycle management for it.
So there are a lot of,
again, capabilities
for a developer to
use and leverage
when they're building
those applications.
And they can decide
the rules and how
and what is to be shared.
And a lot features kind of build
in to really made that happen.
STEPHANIE WONG: And
a lot of companies
are now looking
towards microservices.
But microservices
will continue to have
a lot of different recipes.
Successful microservice
architecture
is complex to design,
build, and manage
and there are a lot of
experimentation going on.
But the key is to build
reusable decoupled services that
can scale with the right
levels of governance.
How is Apigee helping to support
microservice architecture?
AMIT ZAVERY: I think general--
if you look at the architecture
evolution in general,
it's idea is to really have
small kind of services,
and kind of decoupled in a way.
Right?
And then the best way
to use those services is
through an API.
So what Apigee does is,
now that we have interfaces
to a lot of the microservices
management layer,
and for example, Istio, which
Google provides as a service,
allows you to now expose
those microservices,
manage them in a much
better way, and orchestrate
and kind of do a lot of
monitoring around it.
And what we do with Apigee
is we integrate with Istio
and really provide
the ability to manage
those APIs through one of
those channels, one way.
Otherwise, if you have other
microservices, you have an API,
we can of course manage
that lifecycle for that
and allow you to use
those microservices
in a much better fashion than
a [INAUDIBLE] application would
be.
RETO MEIER: Nice.
Can you talk a little bit about
the new general availability
release of Apigee Edge
for a private cloud?
AMIT ZAVERY: Yeah.
I think the way we're
looking at Apigee in general
is to have a deployment
model which is flexible.
All right?
So one is to be
able to, of course,
you can continue
using it On-Prem.
Second thing is to be able
to now take it in the cloud.
We have an Apigee Edge product
that's available in the cloud,
as well, fully
managed by Google.
Third is this hybrid
mechanism, where
you can have some of the runtime
running anywhere you choose,
be it the private
cloud or On-Premise,
you can be running on
Kubernetes with GKE,
and the control plane
is running in the cloud.
And that could be
in any cloud, could
be Google or any third
party cloud, as well.
So we try to make sure the
architecture is very flexible,
giving choices to the
customers and developers
to really deploy the
way they would want to.
And specifically with Edge,
we do provide a private cloud
edition where you
can run on GKE.
And GKE On-Premise can
be available anywhere,
if you ever want to
choose to deploy it.
And we allow you to kind of
have it very easy to manage
and easy to deploy.
So that's available today and
we continue to make progress
in that area.
STEPHANIE WONG: That's exciting.
So we know that APIs
and building APIs
isn't just enough, you
have to actually convince
your developers to use
them and that means
developer portals become key.
How does Apigee's Developer
Portal and its enhancements
help that happen?
AMIT ZAVERY: Yeah.
I think to tie
everything together
you have to have a structure
where this information can
be available.
Right?
So the developers,
of course, would
love to have one way in terms
of how you manage the APIs,
but how you expose it is
to a developer portal.
So Apigee provides a
lot of capabilities
on the Developer Portal site.
So we have a customer facing
portal, a partner facing
portal, all the lifecycle for
getting API into the portal,
as well all the services
that are available.
So the developer doesn't have to
do a lot of the heavy lifting,
in terms of how to
share that content, how
things get the right kind
of security around it.
So the Developer Portal
today is available to all
of our products and we keep
on making enhancements to it.
There's one offering to Drupal
as well, to a third party
CMS if a customer chooses
to use a heavy duty portal
and has a lot more capabilities
for a lot of specific things,
custom work you
might want to do.
But we also have an
integrated portal as part
of our offering today, which
is very simple, easy to use,
and you can create a lot of
portal interfaces for end users
very quickly and easily.
RETO MEIER: That's great.
Now Apigee is built
on best practice
to help create world-class
developer experiences, right?
So tell me a little
bit more about that.
AMIT ZAVERY: I
think in general--
I think, just not Apigee,
you can look at Google,
we've been trying to make
sure the Google Cloud makes
developer experience
very friendly.
Right?
And I think one of the
key things for developers
is a lifecycle of, how do
you create an application
and deliver that.
And the one big part of that
is the API management for it,
in terms of the whole lifecycle.
So we have made sure,
for a developer,
it's very easy to onboard.
They can start writing an API.
They can start documenting
it, testing it, and design
and delivering it.
So we provide a lot of
tooling for that, very simple,
easy to use.
And what we've been
doing beyond that
is really now kind of
giving you metering,
monitoring, monetization.
So now you have an idea of
who's using what, what kind
of security you have,
what kind of privileges
were provided to that user,
as well as what kind of usage
you got out of it, and how
much money you can make out.
So you have a lot of
that data available to
at your fingertips.
So we've been
doing a lot of work
to really add a lot of this
value add, beyond just being
able to build an
API and deliver it,
but also all the things you
needed on monitoring, metering,
security, monetization.
So that's really becoming
a very powerful element
into the feature capabilities
for developers and anybody
else who do this work.
STEPHANIE WONG: Thank
you so much, Amit.
We packed a lot of info into our
talk, so thanks for your time.
AMIT ZAVERY: Oh,
thanks for having me.
[MUSIC PLAYING]